PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode
of "Deconstructing
Chatbots," we will
continue to help the pulse team
extend their single-flow agent
into a multi-flow agent that
can handle not just orders
but also returns.
We will also see how they can
manage multiple agent versions
and deploy to
different environments.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before we dive into the console,
let's lay out the Use Case
requirements first.
Most of Puggs's customer
requests are of three types--
orders, returns, and exchanges.
Each of these requests have
their own conversational twists
and turns and three different
teams that manage those.
We recommend Puggs to
create three separate flows
for these requests.
Multiple flows allows
different teams
to be responsible for building
and maintaining those flows.
And they provide better
conversational control,
help scale quickly,
and they don't
incur any additional cost.
We already created the order
flow in the previous episode.
If you haven't watched
it, it is linked below.
Stop and watch that one
before continuing here,
because this is going to be
the extension of that episode.
We will be creating
a return flow
so Puggs can take return
requests through the Virtual
Agent.
We will keep the flow
simple by just collecting
the order number and providing
a return confirmation.
So now that we know
what we are building,
let's head to the
Dialogflow CX console.
Let's continue working
in our Puggs project.
Add two flows to it for
return and exchange.
In our return flow
at the start page,
we define our transition
route to order.return intent,
which will understand
the user's intent.
Add a few examples
of training phrases,
such as I need a refund.
I would like to return my order.
Add a few more along
the same lines.
And before saving this, let's
add the transition to a page
to collect return information.
In this page, let's ask the
user for the order number.
I've provided a
few examples here.
To process a return, we
need the order number,
so we will make that as
a required parameter.
And for now, let's just
select a system entity number,
although in real life,
Puggs would probably
have a custom entity with a
certain sequence of numbers
that would be matched to their
back end through the web hub.
At this state, we check
if the order number is
received by adding
the condition,
page.params.status equals FINAL.
Once the condition is
met, we want to transition
to another page to provide
a return confirmation.
At the return confirmation
page, all we do
is send a confirmation saying
your return is processed,
adding our session
parameter order number
in there using the dollar sign.
And we transition from
here to the end page.
Although we could transition
to another flow as well if you
wanted the user to, say, take
a survey or order more things.
There's a lot more that
you can do in returns,
you could add more
parameters to collect,
connect to the
Puggs' back in API.
But I will leave that
to you to explore,
since the point of this video is
to get you familiar with the CX
console and the concepts.
Now, we know that Puggs
has multiple teams working
on the flows.
They need the ability
to save progress
by creating different
versions and then
deploy specific
versions of their flows
to development, testing,
or production environments.
Let me show you how versions
and environments work
in Puggs agent.
We go to the Manage tab and in
deployment we find versions.
Now here, since Puggs
has multiple flows,
each flow can have
its own version
so the teams can independently
manage their own versions.
Versions are snapshots
of the flow data
and associated agent data like
intents, entities, web posts,
pages, [INAUDIBLE]
groups, and a lot more.
Now, if we click on
a flow here, let's
say return, create a version.
Give it a name and description
and give it a few seconds
to become ready.
And if we want to
use this version,
then we can just load
it in our drafts load
by clicking on this button.
But let's make another
version so we can actually
see these changes.
Say in this new version, we made
a change to our entry dialog.
Then, go to the versions
and load a previous version.
We see that the change
we made is not there
anymore because we are now
working in an older version.
So that's how
versioning works in CX.
Now as a best practice,
Puggs obviously
wants to separate their
production and development
environments to make sure the
development can keep going
while production is stable.
To do that, we go to
environments and create
a new environment.
Let's say production
in this case.
And we select the corresponding
flow versions that
should be used in production.
We can do the same to set up
dev and test environments too.
Now, once environments
are set up,
make sure you are testing
things in the right environment.
In the simulator, you can
select the environment
and the corresponding flow.
If you're using the API,
pass the environment ID
in the URL like this.
Otherwise, it uses the
default environment,
which is your draft flow.
All right.
With that, we have
created a multi-flow agent
for Puggs's team that
takes orders and returns.
We also learned how
versions and environments
work in Dialogflow CX.
Now, it's your turn.
Design the third exchange
flow for Puggs's team
and share your experience
with me in the comments below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]